monsieur professeur vous êtes l'un des
spécialistes des enjeux économiques de
l'énergie vous avez été le conseiller du
ministre en charge de l'économie vous
êtes aujourd'hui le conseiller de
l'union des industries et métiers de la
métallurgie
vous avez également été membre de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie et
vous êtes aujourd'hui un membre du
comité de prospective de la commission
de régulation de l'énergie alors nous
sommes actuellement et je le disais au
début de mon propos confronté à une
véritable flambée des prix de l'énergie
avec une multiplication par deux du prix
du marché de gars du gaz par 3 de celui
du pétrole par 9 de celui de
l'électricité par rapport au printemps
2020 cette flambée des prix de marché se
répercute sur les tarifs réglementés de
vente se du gaz ont augmenté d'environ
12 5 % en octobre et ceux de
l'électricité pourraient augmenter dans
une même proportion en février
si cette flambée des prix se confirme et
l emporterait de très lourdes
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages mais aussi sur le coût de
production des entreprises opérant ainsi
durablement les perspectives de relance
de notre économie mais aussi celle de sa
décarbonation en effet les dépenses qui
sont liées à l'énergie représente et
2300 euros par ménage en 2010 soit et
8,5 pour cent de leur budget selon
l'institut national de la statistique et
des études économiques l'insee c'est
autant que l'habillement et où les
loisirs de plus ces dépenses concentrées
90 millions d'euros pour le secteur de
l'industrie en 2017 et cela toujours
selon l'insee ces dépenses sont d'autant
plus élevés pour les entreprises energia
energo intensive c'est à dire celles qui
sont fortement consommatrices d'énergie
et notamment dans les secteurs de la
métallurgie de la chimie de la papeterie
ou encore de la cimenterie au nombre de
200 ces entreprises englobe une
consommation d'énergie de 60 5
térawattheures soit la moitié de la
consommation du secteur de l'industrie
selon l'union française de l'électricité
si la situation est donc critique la
réaction des pouvoirs publics et pour le
mois encore balbutiante certes le
premier ministre jean castex a annoncé
le 30 septembre dernier la mise en
oeuvre d'un bouclier tarifaire avec un
blocage des tarifs réglementés du gaz à
partir d'octobre une limitation à quatre
pour cent de la hausse des tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité
prévue en février et une hausse de 100
euros du chèque énergie par ailleurs la
commissaire européenne en charge de
l'énergie mesdames kadri simpson a
annoncé le 22 septembre une boîte à
outils permettant aux états membres de
recourir à des aides ciblées aux
consommateurs à des paiements directs
aux personnes en situation de précarité
énergétique à des réductions de taxes
sur l'énergie ou à des transferts de
charges vers la fiscalité est générale
la constitution de stocks stratégiques
de gaz à l'échelle européenne est aussi
à l'étude pour autant la réponse
apportée par la france peut sembler en
retrait certains pays européens ont pris
des mesures beaucoup plus forte avec une
baisse de la tva c'est le cas en espagne
ou en italie avec des compensations
budgétaire c'est le cas au royaume uni
ou en pologne certains acteurs ont donc
appelé la france à faire davantage l'ufc
que choisir associations de
consommateurs et une iden union des
entreprises utilisatrices d'énergie
regroupement à une d'industriels ont
ainsi plaidé pour un relèvement du
plafond de l'accès régulé à l'énergie
nucléaire historique
la reine dans ce contexte très perturbé
je souhaiterais monsieur le professeur
vous soumettre quatre séries de
questions avant que bien évidemment mes
collègues après vous avoir entendu vous
pose je n'en doute pas un certain nombre
de questions
tout d'abord comment caractériseriez
vous la flambée actuelle des prix des
énergies est ce pour vous une évolution
globale quelles que soient les énergies
et les pays où est-ce une évolué est ce
une évolution durable susceptible de
peser sur les prochains mois
ma deuxième question plus encore quelles
sont les causes de cette flambée des
prix des facteurs conjoncturels tels que
la reprise de l'économie mondiale
au sortir de la crise de lakovic 19
explique-t-il l'essentiel de cette
évolution
al'inverse douati d'autant y voir des
facteurs structurels
à l'instar à l'instar de la tarification
du carbone dans le cadre de la
transition énergétique
troisième question pour répondre à cette
flambée les mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement et par la commission
européenne
bout par est elle suffisante ou faut-il
faire davantage en baissant la fiscalité
énergétique en augmentant les aides aux
ménages aux entrées et aux entreprises
ou en révisant des mécanismes de
régulation comme le dispositif de la
reine où les stocks stratégiques de gaz
enfin dernière question en l'absence de
mesures appropriées quel pourrait être
qu'elle pourrait n'être pas cependant
les conséquences cette flambée pour les
ménages et pour les entreprises une
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat de la
compétitivité et une fille d de la
croissance peut-elle être à prévoir et à
craindre faut-il s'attendre à des
faillites
un temps un des faillites d'entreprises
energo intensive voir des fournisseurs
d'énergie comme cela se passe au royaume
uni faut-il craindre une hausse de la
précarité énergétique qui touche déjà
3,5 millions de ménages selon
l'observatoire national de la précarité
énergétique
voilà déjà un certain nombre de
questions qui vous sont soumises je vous
laisse la parole monsieur le professeur
et a déçu bien sûr de votre audition et
bien j'ouvrirai donc la discussion avec
l'ensemble de nos collègues et on
commencera bien sûr par notre collègue
daniel grémillet qui préside le groupe
nrj c'est à vous merci beaucoup merci
madame la présidente vous mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vais donc
excusez-moi
brossé un tableau des causes de la crise
pas vraiment anticipé par un pas mal de
spécialistes il vous vient de
reconnaître des sur la poule le prix du
gaz naturel dans toute la nuit 2021 ce
qui me permettra de faire des dessins
certain nombre d'éléments de constant
que j'utiliserai dans un deuxième temps
pour répondre aux questions de la
présidente notamment sur la question de
savoir si la crise est majoritairement
conjoncturelle ou structurelle
donc pour tuer le suspense il me semble
qu'elle est majoritairement d'origine
conjoncturel
est ce qui peut avoir un impact à mon
sens aussi sur les mesures de politique
économique qui sont souhaitables dans ce
contexte là
puisque prend des mesures de politique
économique y aurait des effets durables
sur le marché pour traiter un sujet qui
est plutôt conjoncturel il peut y avoir
un hiatus qui est pas souhaitable enfin
je rentrerai dans le détail ensuite
j'aborderai dans un troisième point de
la présentation du marché de
l'électricité ça sans pouvoir aller plus
vite puisque l'essentiel de l'envolée
des prix d'électricité est due à
l'envolée des marchés du prix du gaz
donc là j'y reviendrai aussi je
reviendrai sur certaines déclarations de
responsables politiques récents qui
soulignent le fait que le marché
européen l'électricité avait un
fonctionnement aberrant économiquement
et écologiquement
je suis pas sûr que ce soit tout à fait
car mais je vous donnerai quelques
arguments qui à mon avis le centre
défendre quand même le type de
fonctionnement du marché européen
d'électricité même s'il peut sembler un
peu original c'est vrai au premier abord
et puis ensuite j'aborderai peut-être un
certain nombre de questions qui ont été
soulevées on a effleuré la question
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments de
l'efficacité énergétique pour moi c'est
très important c'est un petit peu la
difficulté parler d'énergie la
transition énergétique c'est que en fait
il ya des leviers partout et des conti a
un fils c'est comme dans le jeu de
mikado il ya un autre il ya un autre
bâton qui vient
j'avais fait ma thèse sur la réforme des
retraites la réforme des retraites même
si c'est compliqué à la fin il ya quand
même que trois leviers dans la
transition énergétique y en a une
quinzaine et il faut les années il faut
les harmoniser les uns les autres donc
si je parle d'un sujet je vais avoir du
mal à ne pas parler tous les autres mais
je ne serai pas trop long et comme tout
universitaire je peux parler longtemps
madame la présidente donc vous ne couvre
pendant que vous me couper quand vous en
avez marre ce que je peux durer 18
heures là dessus il est crucial et puis
peut-être n'ai-je tend une perche vous
la saisir et ou pas su si je suis là
pour parler d'énergie mais la transition
énergétique ça aussi des conséquences
sur les métaux
sujet dont on parle peu c'est pas
l'énergie mais c'est quand même matière
première et s'est retiré de l'écorcé
terrestre donc je ne suis pas là pour
vous faire l'article sur les métaux mais
si vous voulez que je donne deux trois
éléments là dessus sur le cuivre sur
l'aluminium sur les terres rares parce
que là tout est à la hausse et là c'est
structurel
alors sur le marché du gaz
bien que vous le savez les tarifs
réglementés de vente au détail du gaz
ont été relevés de 12 6% tout est
comprise au 1er octobre 2021
si on regarde l'évolution depuis le 1er
janvier 2019 on est à + 29 %
comme les prix du gaz ont beaucoup
baissé en 2020 depuis le début du 1er
janvier 2020 on est à + 45 % de ces
tarifs qui comme vous le savez sont
fixés par le gouvernement en doute le
sujet alors là je me lève au dessus de
mon humble conditions le sujet est
évidemment politiquement ultra sensible
puisque on paye sa facture
énergie soit tous les mois sur tous les
trimestres en tout cas ça se voit et
l'effet est immédiat et direct et
j'allais dire homothétique c'est à dire
ça tombe sur le comment de consommateurs
boom est dans une période où les débats
publics sont appelés un peu à s'animer
contenu des échanges qu'on connaît alors
ça c'est l'aspect politique y est très
voyant bien sûr du point de vue
économique
en fait les faits va être beaucoup plus
diffus puisque les tarifs réglementés de
vente du gaz ne concerne aucun
industriel ne concerne aucune
collectivité et ne concerne que
29 pourtant oui c'est ça c'est ma
mémoire est bonne des ménages
c'est pas pour minimiser du tout le choc
qui est majeure mais c'est pour dire qu'
il va être diffusé petit à petit dans
l'économie puisque tous ces acteurs que
j'ai cités tout à leur entreprise
collectivité et ses 71 % de ménages sont
dix ans tarifs de marché c'est-à-dire
contractualiser avec leur famille leurs
fournisseurs et la plupart de ses tarifs
sont à prix fixe c'est à dire que les
opérateurs sur le marché du gaz vendent
à prix fixe et pour éviter d'être
concernées par le risque de marché qui
résulterait du fed d'acheter sur le
marché de gros des volumes de prix du
gaz au prix marché ils ont recours aux
marchés dérivés au marché futures et ils
se couvrent contre cela donc à la fin
c'est le marché financier qui gèrent en
ce moment il ya beaucoup de gens
finances et qui perdent de l'argent en
ce moment mais le secteur gazier pour le
coup il évite de se ressourcer à des
prix très élevés de vendre à des prix
relativement faible sur ses clients à
tarifs de marché donc
à court terme les faits et pas majeur
après il va se diffuser comme un espèce
de petit poisson blanc dans les mois qui
viennent ce qui est effectivement un
sujet un sujet de
d'inquiétude je rappelle que les tarifs
réglementés de vente du gaz vont
disparaître au 1er juillet 2023 donc
s'il ya une nouvelle explosion des prix
du gaz dans deux ans je n'aurai pas le
plaisir d'être convoqué devant votre
commission puisqu'il y aura plus de
tarifs réglementés des ventes de prix du
gaz et donc il y aurait plus de
visibilité politique
alors je me rapproche du micro je me
rapproche des micros pas de souci ces
jeux et je parlais comme un professeur
dans un an 6 mais c'est pas mon rôle ici
donc les il y aura plus de tarifs
réglementés de vente du prix du gaz au
1er juillet 2023 ce qui fait que le
sujet politique tombera tout cela
passera sous l'écran du radar si je puis
dire puisque ça sera renégocié dans les
contrats individuellement alors
je dirais que cette augmentation des
tarifs de détail c'est évidemment la
face émergée de l'iceberg puisque la
face émergée de l iceberg c'est les prix
de gros les prix du gaz naturel liquéfié
sur le marché mondial et puis les prix
du gaz sur le marché européen alors le
marché du gaz dans le monde il est
divisé en trois régions et c'est
important d'avoir ce en tête parce que
ça des implications sur la nature de la
crise actuelle est donc les réponses a
priori pertinentes à y apporter vous
avez trois régions les états afin de
l'amérique du nord l'europe et l'asie
ça se distingue du marché du pétrole qui
a marché mondial ça se distingue du
marché de l'électricité qui est un
marché essentiellement national même si
elle est injustement aux frontières
le marché du gaz oseo en amérique du
nord l'amérique du nord est à peu près
autosuffisante et exporte même un petit
peu de gaz naturel liquéfié elle en a
exporté beaucoup moins en 2021 parce
qu'ils ont eu des problèmes de
maintenance et donc les états unis au
moins fabriquer de gaz naturel liquéfié
au mois exporter de gaz naturel liquéfié
ils ont eu des problèmes de maintenance
et un certain nombre d' usine de
liquéfaction pas bien tourné aux états
unis ce qui a donc déjà dit mais un
petit peu l'offre de gnl dans le monde
l'asie elle est très peu autonome et
c'est vraiment le grand centre de
consommation du gaz naturel liquéfié
dans le monde elle produit un peu de gaz
mais peut
il ya un tuyau qui est en train de
partir de russie qui arrive en chine
mais c'est encore petit est le principal
consommateur de gaz naturel liquéfié
jusqu'à récemment c'était le japon est
le principal consommateur de gaz naturel
liquéfié depuis cette année c'est la
chine
dont la demande en 2021 de gaz a
augmenté de 15% donc quand vous avez un
pays d'un milliard trois cents millions
d'habitants dont la demande de gaz
augmente de 15% c'est la panique sur
dans le petit monde des méthaniers
puisque en fait vous avez un effet
d'aspirateurs qui fait qu'il reste plus
de méthaniers pour l'europe puisque
l'europe
lll et moins dépendants du gaz fallait
moins dépendante du gaz naturel liquéfié
elle produit du gaz ont produit encore
beaucoup de gaz en europe du nord
norvège
royaume-uni est le produit du gaz sur le
continent pays bas même si j'y
reviendrai c'est de moins en moins l
import du gaz par gazoduc
on y reviendra il ya quatre gazoducs
russes qui nous arrive dessus celui qui
est north stream qui arrive en allemagne
yamal qui passe par la pologne et
l'allemagne
le tuyaux ukrainiens qui n'est pas très
remplie en ce moment on y viendra qui
est donc un petit peu en dessous diamal
et puis à blue stream qui passe sous la
mer noire et qui arrivent dans les pays
d'europe orientale on y reviendra et
donc normalement le gaz naturel liquéfié
pour l'europe c'est c'est un peu le
l'approvisionnement d'appoint sauf que
on a eu des problèmes d'offre de gaz en
europe à cause de la crise du covili les
travaux de maintenance ont pas pu être
fait sur les plates formes offshore en
mer du nord en 2020 parce qu'il avait
personne
l'industrie des hydrocarbures
normalement elle est très
précautionneuse quand il s'agit de
travaux de sécurisation de maintenance
ou autres donc ils n'en ont pas fait en
ils ont fait tous en 2021 donc la mer du
nord a produit moins c'est temporaire c
circonstancielle normalement dans les
mois qui viennent ça va revenir
les pays bas produisent moins mais ça
c'est structurel ils ont un champ qui
s'appelle grenade qui est un chant
gigantesque puisque ça fait 40 ans qu'il
produit normalement un champ de gaza
dure pas beaucoup plus de 25 ans est la
grande vague est en train en fait de
s'épuiser et le pays bas qui les pays
bas qui était une grande grands pays
gazier est en train de en fait de sortir
du gaz
donc la baisse de production de grenade
ça c'est structurel ils vont par pousser
les feux le réservoir est en train de
s'épuiser alors après il ya les
importations bon
le fêter que
gazprom ne fait pas absolument ce qu'il
veut en matière de volume exporté en
france parce qu'il est lié par des
contrats à long terme qui ont été signés
il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans il ya vingt
ans qui définissent très précisément le
montant de gaz que gazprom doit livrer
en fonction de la demande de ses clients
donc pour parler dans un mauvais
français ou un bon anglais il n'est pas
market maker sur le marché on n'est pas
on peut pas dire qu'on aime excusez moi
dans la main des ruches
mais en moins ils ont une petite marge
de manoeuvre que selon toute probabilité
ils ont utilisé dans la semaine qui dans
les semaines passent et qui fait qu' ils
peuvent utiliser une partie du tuyau
ukrainien pour en mettre un peu plus ou
un peu moins et là ils sont pas liés par
des contrats c'est comme ils veulent ils
ont l'option de remplir le tuyau ou pas
ils ne l'ont pas fait il aurait pu le
faire
ils ne l'ont pas fait et quand on
connaît un peu gazprom bon enfin on sait
que les gars ils savent faire le calcul
donc évidemment il ya une explosion du
prix du gaz si vous faites un peu de
rétention vous alimentez
ce prix élevé et on a toutes les raisons
de penser qu'ils sont sont pas privés
même si les informations sont pas
toujours très facile à voir le président
poutine a fait une déclaration il ya
quelques jours en disant on va alimenter
on va alimenter ça me permet de
souligner un point c'est qu'au plus fort
de la crise du prix du gaz en europe sur
le marché on a dû taper à 150 160 euros
le mégawattheure aux environs et avant
votre commission j'ai pris le soin de
vérifier on est à 85 donc c'est pas pour
dire qu' il n'y a pas de problème c'est
pour dire que ça va vite ça monte vite
mais ça peut baisser vite et la question
en fait aujourd'hui de savoir est pas de
savoir si on va redescendre on est déjà
redescendu
la question c'est de savoir en combien
de temps on va revenir de 85 aujourd'hui
à un prix normal qui est de l'ordre de
15 20 euros le mégawattheure la question
c'est celle là ça va descendre à quelle
vitesse alors à quelle vitesse ça va
dépendre des ruches et ça va dépendre de
la météo
donc c'est là où la compétence
d'économiste va s'arrêter un film ans et
que l'évolution du prix du gaz va être
en partie lié par les températures de
cet hiver
et là j'ai pas d'idée très particulière
évidemment ce que je peux dire c'est que
l'été l'hiver dernier a été froid en
asie ce et que déjà cette époque là les
importations des races de gaz naturel
liquéfié ont bondi on a eu déjà un pic
de prix considérables en asie à cause de
sa bourse il fait froid cet hiver bah
c'est sûr que la baisse des prix du gaz
se sera pas pour cet hiver
alors il ya comme vous le voyez on a du
peu d'offres sur le marché européen
puisqu'il y avait peu de productions il
y avait peu d'importance gazoducs et
puis on n'arrivera pas à voir les méta
nikki partis tous en asie
et pendant ce temps là on avait une
demande qui redémarrait on a eu un écart
sur le marché européen très important
entre l'offre et la demande de l'ordre 6
% 10 % c'est-à-dire que liliane un écart
entre cette offre est cette demande de
gaz 10% ça évidemment contribué à
renchérir le prix du gaz est là parce
qu'il faut quand même être positif un
peu là on a été sauvée c'est grâce aux
stocks
on a déstockage en europe qui sont
importants le gaz ce stock assez
facilement un coup assez raisonnable ce
qui n'est pas le cas de l'électricité
pour le moment est en fait cette c30 le
milliard de mètres cubes de déficit
entre l'offre et la demande ont été
couverts par des stocks
alors la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a
suffisamment de stock pour passer divers
impôts c'est oui en france et non
ailleurs
donc oui en france parce qu'on a des
stocks qui sont vraiment bien remplie
mais les stocks en allemagne aux pays
bas sont vraiment pas remplies
alors c'est le verre à moitié plein ou à
moitié vide là à moitié plein en france
normalement on va pouvoir passer l'hiver
sans trop de problèmes à moitié vide
c'est que si toute l'europe nous demande
de taper dans nos stocks on en aura pas
assez et là on aura un problème partout
dans le continent donc ça c'est si c'est
ce qui se passerait s'il faisait
vraiment froid et si les ruches continue
à faire de la rétention
scénario pessimiste
pas impossible
mais c'est pas un peu physiquement c'est
pas face à ces voix là c'est impossible
il faut avoir en tête
alors que dire d'autre sûr je pense que
j'ai brossé l'essentiel des causes du
marché du gaz il ya aussi un élément qui
me permet d'introduire le prix du
carbone c'est qu'on pourrait se dire bon
mais puisque le gaz a autant augmenter
pourquoi est-ce qu'on utilise encore
pour fabriquer l'électricité est ce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de pays en
europe la pologne l'allemagne qui
pourrait le fabriqué à partir du charbon
je suppose que c'est pour la bonne
bouche
au premier semestre 2010 21 l'allemagne
la production d'électricité allemande a
été davantage issue du charbon que
d'énergies renouvelables
c'est à dire qu'il ya de 23% sur 3 de
l'électricité allemande produits au
premier semestre l'était à partir de
lignite et comme il ya eu moins de vent
joignent à oyem comme il ya eu moins de
vent en mer du nord au premier semestre
merci il ya eu moins de production
d'électricité d'origine éolienne et donc
ils ont produit plus d'élèves d'origine
charbonnières que delek d'origine le n r
je dis ça je dis rien évidemment et
pendant ce temps là évidemment le prix
du
co2 sur les quotas d'émission a beaucoup
augmenté et ça c'est structurel ça ces
structures a essentiellement
structurelles c'est un peu lié à la
demande et quand le prix du quota de gaz
a beaucoup augmenté que le quota que le
quota de co2 pardon a beaucoup augmenté
ça pénalise davantage de charbon de gaz
que le gaz donc on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation où même si le prix du gaz
avaient beaucoup augmenté il restait
compétitif par rapport aux prix à
l'électricité fabriqué à partir de
charbon et co2 je sais pas si je suis
par le chinois enfin voilà enfin en gros
si vous voulez l'explosion du prix du
gaz sur le marché en 2021 c'est le
résultat d'un concours de mauvaises
circonstances un peu extraordinaire
parce que si j'ajoute le prix du co2 qui
augmente plus les ruches les anglais les
pays-bas la chine les américains qui
font pas redémarrer leur train de
liquéfaction
encore deux ou trois autres et la
demande qui rebondit parce qu'on sort de
la crise du président je suis dans un
environnement où j'ai sept ou huit
facteurs qui se cumulent les uns les
autres qui sont pour l'essentiel
conjoncturel pas tous mais pour
l'essentiel est évidemment j'aboutis un
comportement du marché qui pourra les
nerfs pour amener un économise de
l'énergie qui n'est pas aberrante n'est
pas pathologique parce qu'on sait bien
que les prix l'énergie s'est il parle il
est plus volatile de l'économie et que
quand le marché de l'électricité
fonctionne pas bien on peut avoir un
prix du lait qui est multiplié par 10 en
quelques heures ça s'est déjà vu
alors ça m'amène tranquillement je pense
à la
répondre aux questions de la présidente
il ya des questions davantage de
politique énergétique
alors est ce que ces structures et le
conjoncturel s'est essentiellement
conjoncturel je reste sur le marché du
gaz en jeu passe à l'edhec après donc
c'est essentiellement conjoncturelle
combien de temps ça va durer
alors ça dépend ce qu'on appelle long
terme je crois que pour la plupart des
observateurs du débat public le long
terme c'est quelque part du côté de
l'année du début du mois de mai 2022
alors pour un gazier le long terme c'est
dans 20 ans alors ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que
les prix vont sans doute restée
sensiblement plus haut que leur niveau
moyen dans les mois qui viennent
ça c'est plutôt la mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que normalement
vu le concours de circonstances un peu
incroyable qui a fait naître cette
situation il est plutôt raisonnable de
penser que ça va se calmer dans les mois
qui viennent à ce que ça se calmera à
temps et au bon moment ça dépendra des
températures je fais de vos jeux moi je
sais pas mais en tout cas bon le sujet
va pas disparaître de l'écran radar très
vite même si depuis deux semaines après
tout le prix du gaz a été divisé par
deux ans on est passé de 160 à 85 alors
les conséquences pour les ménages et les
entreprises
alors si vous me permettez la présidente
je rajouterais un troisième acteur les
finances publiques
parce que pour moi les finances
publiques c'est les ménages et les
entreprises de demain
parce que si on fait du déficit et de la
dette aujourd'hui forcément demain il ya
quelqu'un qui va payer et ça sera les
ménages et les entreprises alors
deux points là dessus dans la mesure où
le problème me semble-t-il est en bonne
partie d'entre conjoncturelle il me
semble que
il est plus pertinent d'avoir des
mesures réversible ou de court terme ou
qui durent pas longtemps et en tout cas
qui a priori d'en gach pas trop des
facteurs structurels ou découpées rennes
pour les finances publiques ou des
réformes structurelles sur les marchés
bon ça s'est ouvert aux débats bien sûr
c'est ce qu'il ya c'est ce qui résulte
un peu d'une analyse technique ce qui
veut dire que
la question du chèque énergie bas
effectivement c'est ça je pense que ça a
été en plus proposé par cette commission
donc ça quand il faut qu'on opère vite
bah c'est ce qu'on fait c'est à dire
quand vous êtes sur un vélo vous avez
fait une crevaison ben vous changez pas
à la roue tout de suite vous mettez une
rustine pour aller aux mazures au
magasin plus le plus proche c'est pas à
l'extase de mettre une rustine mais ça
vous permet de vous sortir un court
terme de la situation donc donc très
bien et puis quand j'étais à bercy on a
fait des trucs comme ça quand il fallait
le faire alors après la question du
blocage des prix de l'énergie
ça c'est une longue histoire
puisque la première fois que des prix de
l'énergie ont été bloqués je m'en
souviens c'est bien c'est en avril 2011
c'était françois fillon à l'époque on
était aussi dans une période pré pré
débat public on va dire ça comme ça la
difficulté c'est qu'il ya des lois qui
normalement s'assure que
les tarifs réglementés de vente couvre
les coûts et c'est la commission de
régulation de l'énergie qui regard de
cela donc tout ce qui a été fait
maintenant me semble aller à l'aune de
ce critère législatif plutôt aller dans
le bon sens mais si les prix continuent
à augmenter
peut-être qu'à un moment ou un autre la
question va se poser je pense notamment
c'est une autre vague de hausse des prix
du gaz après le mois d'octobre ce qui
n'est pas impossible donc c'est un sujet
de sujets de préconisations est ce que
le gouvernement on a assez fait alors là
pour le coup
dans la droite ligne de ce que je viens
de dire comme il a pris des mesures
relativement temporaire j'aurais
tendance à lui suggérer de ne pas en
faire beaucoup plus en tout cas de ne
pas engager des choses qui diminuerait
par exemple le déficit structurel il ya
quand même un point où je suis chiffonné
donc là je vais me rattraper dans la
présidente tout ce que je voulais un
truc cercles de
là où j'étais un peu chiffonné c'est que
rien n'a été annoncé sur l'isolation
thermique des bâtiments parce que quand
vous donnez un chèque de 100 euros à
quelqu'un qui en précarité énergétique
est plutôt pauvre il a quand même
probabilité assez élevé dans une
passoire énergétique et finalement de
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour
maintenir en 21 degrés son logement
alors que sa fille de tous les côtés
donc si à la limite on a de l'argent à
mettre sur la table ce qui ne sont pas
déraisonnable à court terme
pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en mettrais pas
davantage sur une isolation thermique un
peu accéléré et au forceps parce que là
en fait ce qu'on paye des ménages
pauvres qui ont froid chez eux qui ont
des maladies chroniques qui ça fait des
dépenses d'assurance maladie alors que
si on mettait un programme accéléré je
sais que le sujet n'est pas facile et
vous connaissez le coin mais d'isolation
thermique des bâtiments vous avez
dépenser votre argent public que vous
avez façon prévu de dépenser mais
au moins à long terme ces gens là seront
moins dans des passoires énergétiques et
en gros au moins la grille donc je crois
que tant qu'à dépenser l'argent à court
terme il faut essayer le dépenser de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent contribuer
à résoudre des problèmes de long terme
même si l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments c'est un sujet complexe que
d'ailleurs je crois vous connaissez
particulièrement bien alors j'ajoute
aussi que
là je parle finances publiques
bon on sort d'une crise macro économie
considérable vous avez peut-être garder
la note de conjoncture de l'insee qui a
dû sortir le 6 octobre le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages a augmenté en 2020
enfin augmenterait en 2021 de 1 5%
après n'avoir pas baissé en 2020 alors
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit je dis pas que les gens sont
contents je dis pas que c'est pas des
gens qui sont précarité énergétique je
dis pas qu'il ya des bas revenus je dis
simplement que l'effet de la crise a été
complètement amortis pour les ménages il
a essuyé aussi été complètement amortis
pour les entreprises via les dispositifs
de chômage partiel et c'est très bien et
qui a amorti le choc et les finances
publiques qui ont été ultra sollicité
ma tendance ça va vite ça engage que moi
mais je pense que l'accumulation de la
dette publique ça pose un problème
d'équité entre les générations
j'observe une petite parenthèse que on
est un pays où les questions d'inégalité
à juste titre sont très sensibles léger
les jaunes en ont beaucoup parlé il ya
une inégalité
massives dont on ne parle jamais c'est
l'inégalité entre les générations qui
associée à l'accumulation de dettes
publiques et c'est là on n'en parle
jamais jamais alors je suis un peu
sensible au sujet parce que tous les
travaux académiques sur les retraites et
sur la transition énergétique c'est sur
l'équité intergénérationnelle
mais juste vous pour vous donner un
exemple un indicateur qui est calculée
par le cdr qui s'appelle le fiscaux le
gap qui dit simplement moi je la fais
courte
quel niveau déficit qu'il faudrait avoir
dans un pays pour qu'il assure l'équité
entre les générations et un retour de la
dette publique à un niveau correct
réponse en france il faudrait un surplus
budgétaire
d'un pour cent
et en allemagne eh ben ils ont le bon
niveau de déficit ils ont une dette
publique qui a pas beaucoup augmenté
donc de part et d'autre du rhin il ya un
traitement de ces questions d'inégalité
intergénérationnel via la dette publique
qui est très différent donc je
sais un peu de maquereaux
mais je veux attirer votre attention
attention là dessus et donc je pense que
l'acteur qu'il faut un peu protégés
maintenant me semble-t-il ses finances
publiques alors
est-ce que ça concerne toutes les
énergies toutes les matières premières
oui ça concerne même beaucoup aussi les
métaux je pourrais en trouver si ça vous
intéresse mais je vais pas prolonger là
dessus je vends une perche vous
l'apprendrez ou pas mais par exemple la
transition énergétique c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui pousse à la hausse de
façon structurelle le prix du cuivre le
prix de la lui la transition numérique
énergétique ça pousse à la hausse de
façon structurelle le prix des terres
rares le prix du platine vous en avez un
peu dans nos smartphones le prix de
l'indium vous en avez sur vos écrans
tactiles le prix du palladium le prix du
néodyme vous en avez dans les aimants
semi permanents qui sont dans la nacelle
de votre de votre éolienne et tout ça
c'est structurel
alors je viens à l'électricité alors ça
ira plus vite puisque 80 % ça c'est une
règle de 3 80% de la hausse du prix de
l'électricité
est liée à l'envolée du prix du gaz les
20% restants sont comme je les dis qu'il
ya plutôt structurés conjoncturelle à
mon avis le reste les 20% c'est plutôt
lié à l'envol du prix des quotas de co2
qui sont pas celles en gros de 20 $ 20
euros la tonne en 2020 à 60 aujourd'hui
alors sur
l'électricité
habituellement les prix l'électricité
c'est entre 50 de production sont entre
50 euros et 100 euros le mégawattheure
on vole joyeusement entre 150 et 250
euros mégawattheure je sais pas si
facile et ça fait des semaines que ça
dure c'est vraiment très très c'est pas
anodin du tout c'était vraiment rarement
arrivé dans le passé alors des
responsables et non des moindres ont pu
dire que le fonctionnement l'électricité
européen était aberrant que pourquoi est
ce que le producteur marginal qui est un
gazier pourquoi est-ce qu'on paierait
l'électricité
en fonction de ce prix du gaz alors bon
je ne suis pas d'accord
parce que
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
si le prix le marché l'électricité
fonctionne comme ça en europe c'est que
c'est comme ça qu'on minimise le coût
moyen de production d'électricité on ne
produit pas de l'électricité que à
partir du nucléaire on ne produit pas
d'électricité que à partir des non
renouvelable n'est qu' à partir du gaz
pourquoi parce qu'on sait pas stocker
l'électricité pour le moment j'y
reviendrai donc il faut avoir un panel
de technologies est la question que je
pose à l'économie c'est là je vais
minimiser les coûts globaux je vais
employer mes moyens de formation les
moyens de production en fonction de la
répartition coûts fixes coûts variables
et là vous obtenez ce qu'on appelle un
parc optimale c'est à dire vous avez du
nucléaire donc jeudi pour puisque la
question passera sans doute poser donc
en gros l'analyse économique elle vous
dit que le nucléaire si je mets de côté
les questions environnementales qui sont
pas des gens mais moi je suis prof
d'économie donc je m'intéresse aux
questions de coûts et de prix le
nucléaire la part optimale du nucléaire
dans un mixer quelque part entre 60 et
75 % si je mets de côté la question
environnementale qui n'est pas
négligeable une question débat public
c'est un peu au delà de pauvres
compétences mais si je regarde les prix
ou les coûts compte tenu du fait que le
nucléaire il ya beaucoup de coûts fixes
et très peu le coût variable c'est
pertinent de le faire fonctionner à peu
près 60% du temps en gros
et donc pour le reste il faut un
producteur qui puisse produire de
l'électricité
vite
même quand il n'ya pas de soleil
même quand il n'ya pas de vent
il y en a deux qui s'affairent cent il
ya un barrage des tchèques
mais ça s'épuise parce qu'à force de
tirer sur votre barrage à la fin il ya
plus d'eau
et celui qui reste c'est la centrale à
gaz parce qu'une centrale à gaz et puis
sur le bouton cinq minutes plus tard
vous avez un tiers de centrales
nucléaires qui arrive sur le réseau
donc si ça fonctionnait pas comme ça
on serait dans le noir on serait dans le
black out
ce qui est encore plus coûteux ce qui
est encore plus coûteux déjà parce que
les activités s'arrête votre bain
d'électrolysé d'aluminium s'arrête à
redémarrer c'est l'eau et puis on n'est
pas sûr de savoir si un réseau qui tombe
dans black out on n'est pas complètement
sûr de savoir si on sait le redémarrer
parce que ça a l'air simple mais il
suffit pas de brancher une centrale
nucléaire sur un mort sur un câble
redémarrer un black out la dernière fois
que ça arrivait en france étaient en 76
alors qu edf s'entraîne mais le jour où
ça arrive qu'on n'est pas sûr que ça
redémarre et là ça pose des problèmes
économiques et même de souveraineté et
de défense nationales considérable donc
ce qu'il faut vraiment éviter c'est le
black out en électricité l'important
c'est la sécurité d'approvisionnement ça
se paye ça ce panier parce que si vous
payez pas sans s'avouer coûter beaucoup
plus cher le jour où il ya un accident
donc il me semble que le fonctionnement
dans ses grandes lignes du marché
européen à l'électricité n'est pas
aberrant
alors
qu'est ce qu'il y a vu d'autres et ce
que je répondu à des questions
d'électricité alors on a parlé du
plafond de la reine alors le plafond de
la reine ça
je vais prudence est un sujet
extrêmement politique si je puis me
permettre ce qui veut dire que je vais
pas vous dire nécessairement beaucoup de
choses
bon les prix sur le marché gros sont
très élevés sur l'électricité une
centrale nucléaire est amorti elle a un
coût de fonctionnement
moi ça dépend des centrales enfin il est
très à marty dont qui se payent aux
environs 30 40 euros pour une centrale
nucléaire installée
donc oui edf gagne de l'argent quand les
prix de marché sont élevés
ils en gagnent même deux fois
une fois parce que y vend plus cher sur
le marché de gros et puis les
dispositifs
vous savez de l'aide
de tarifs d'achat des énergies
renouvelables il fonctionne comme étant
un écart entre le coût de production de
votre éolienne ou de vous du gain qui
fait une usine de photovoltaïque et le
prix de marché comme le prix de marché a
explosé évidemment
l'indemnisation que doit verser edf pour
acheter l'électricité issue d'une
éolienne du photovoltaïque a beaucoup
fondu
donc est-ce qu edf gagne beaucoup
d'argent en ce moment oui
alors après il faut voir la situation au
financière d'edf qui est la sienne qui
ne vit une situation compliquée et c'est
pas trop de sa faute la transition
énergétique ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
et donc après bach là c'est là où je
vais m'arrêter il ya un choix politique
à faire parce que si vous relever le
plafond de la haine évidemment vous
redistribuer une partie de cet argent
qui est en train de gagner df au
bénéfice des consommateurs
bon choix politiques moi en tant que
prof d'économie j'ai pas grand chose à
dire là dessus j'ai qu'une chose à dire
c'est que encore une fois si le problème
est conjoncturelle touché à un logique
et structurelles
moi j'ai un peu de mal en tout cas c'est
un sujet sensible et puis un autre
facteur de complexification de ce
dossier c'est que je n'ignore pas où
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des gens dans
la république ils sont assez sensibles à
la valorisation financière d'edf en vue
d'opérations ultérieure potentiel et que
évidemment ça ça va interférer dans le
raisonnement à partir de la compétence
d'économiste s'arrête et c'est votre
métier c'est clair et c'est plus le mien
mais c'est très sensible parce que le
compteur c'est là le compteur y tournant
milliards d'euros sur le sujet ça va
très vite donc il faut faire attention
alors quelles sont les solutions pour ce
qu'il faut essayer de trouver des
solutions
quelles peuvent être les solutions à 7 à
cette envolée du prix de l'électricité
balle essentiellement c'est ce que je
dis déjà sur le prix du gaz puisque 80%
de l'envolée du prix de l'élec
ailier ou à l'évolution du prix du gaz
moi je soulignerai bien d'autres
d'autres effets à prendre en compte il
ya la question du stockage d'électricité
dans mon métier qui est passionnant le
sera encore plus le jour où le stockage
d'électricité arrivera et il va arriver
alors quand je parle de stockage
d'électricité c'est pas la petite pile
c'est des dispositifs qui aujourd'hui la
taille d'un semi-remorque
la dictature la miniaturisation et est
arrivé mais ce sont des grosses piles
que vous branchez sur les réseaux et qui
peut vous captez comme ça l'équivalent
de 20 mégawatts cependant à peu près 24
heures et qui prennent le surplus
production l'éolien ou du photovoltaïque
et qui leur verse à peu près au bout de
24 heures alors par définition quand
vous avez un et caniche de stockage ça
va lisser la volatilité de la demande et
de l'offre d'électricité salle à
contribuer un peu à lisser les prix
alors chance le progrès technique et
surtout les effets d'échelle font que
bientôt ses technologies de stockage
d'électricité va devenir économiquement
pertinentes les gars de productivité
d'abord des chinois cui aussi un petit
peu les européens font que le coût de
production baissent de 20 à 30% pour ces
grosses batteries stationnaires et ça
c'est l'avenir
pourrait dire en peu de mots mais ce
sera ma conclusion est évidemment la
transition énergétique ça coûte cher
évidemment ça coûte cher mais le point
d'atterrissage final il est très bon
alors vous savez les économistes ont
cette curieuse habitude d'être d'avoir
des idées très claires sur ce qui va se
passer à 50 ans est beaucoup moins
claire ce ce qui va se passer dans six
mois
donc je vais je vais tomber dans ce
travers
mais il me semble que le point
d'atterrissage finale en 2050 il est
assez clair et réjouissances c'est
beaucoup de photovoltaïque et beaucoup
de stockage
beaucoup de photovoltaïque parce que ça
coûte très peu cher on fabrique ça à
partir de silicium et en appelant sur la
croûte terrestre le tellure de cadmium
c'est fini depuis pas mal d'années
c'était toxique mais on n'utilise plus
en est avec beaucoup de stockage et bien
on fabriquera notre électricité avec du
photovoltaïque on mettrait du stockage
partout et quand votre alumineries dans
la vallée de la maurienne devra
fabriquer son alumine son aluminium à 4
heures du matin ce sera des stocks
-qu'ils à fournir ou leur a peut-être du
nucléaire il y aura sans doute du
nucléaire je le souhaite il y aura
peut-être encore un peu de gaz mais il y
aura beaucoup de photovoltaïque et
beaucoup de stockage et ça coûtera pas
cher
le problème c'est que passer du système
actuel à ce système là nécessite des
investissements considérables et ça ça
va coûter cher
donc le stockage c'est une solution
importante un autre solution
bon ça c'est assez peut-être mais dada
peu sonné mais la sobriété énergétique
je pense que là il ya quelque chose à
faire auprès des ménages je trouve que
je faisais un courriel à mes étudiants
sur la transition énergétique moi je
suis un fervent défenseur du pull en
laine
ou du linge de corps
parce que vous n'imaginez pas les
les services économiques et
environnementaux vous rendez en étant un
bon pull en laine et qui fait 19 degrés
chez vous plutôt que d'être en
chemisette à 22 degrés
ça coûte pas cher ça contribue à la
dépendance énergétique de la france
ça promet ça protège l'environnement à
sa sacoche absolument toutes les gaz
le pull en laine c'est vraiment la
politique de l'énergie parfaite
ça a toujours beaucoup de succès mais il
faut pousser pour une fois qu'on fait
des propositions simples à mettre en
oeuvre commence c'est plutôt sympathique
bon j'ai abordé déjà pas mal de sujets
je regarde mes notes ça fait combien de
temps que je parle trop sans doute
aussi à des gens qui sont intéressés par
les métaux gens j'en parlerai mais voilà
c'était pour l'essentiel ce que j'avais
à dire je suis ravi de répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le professeur
avant de passer la parole à daniel
gravier peut-être sûr on entend beaucoup
parler est-ce qu'il faut baisser la
fiscalité énergétique
alors là je suis encore un contre emploi
pour un économiste
a priori la réponse est non alan
pourtant un économiste à une bien payé
mais si les impôts en tout cas moi je
fais partie des économistes qui
aimeraient bien baisser les impôts mais
et les dépenses publiques aussi mais en
la matière de fiscalité énergétique
il faut voir que cette fiscalité est là
pour influencer les comportements des
gens
ce qui me permet d'ailleurs peut-être
sur la fiscalité énergétique de dire
qu'elle a deux effets on pense toujours
alain qui est pas très important et à
l'autre qui est plus important la
fiscalité énergétique et l'a2 eiffel un
effet environnemental
elle pèse sur la consommation produits
polluants ça les gens l'ont bien en tête
le problème c'est qu'elle pèse peu sur
les émissions de polluants parce que la
demande d'énergie est assez inélastique
au prix donc quand vous augmenter de 10%
le prix d'inde un carburant votre
demande va baisser que de 4 à 5% parce
que les gens ils sont obligés de remplir
le réservoir et donc vous avez un effet
amorti sur les émissions de couy la taxe
carbone les taxes environnementales
c'est indispensable
mais ça peut pas être le seul instrument
et puis surtout ce qu'on oublie et ça
c'est alors ces peluches dans la main de
vos collègues des affaires budgétaires
mais c'est un bon sujet il ya un intérêt
fiscal à la taxe carbone aux taxes
environnementales il ya un intérêt
fiscal si en même temps vous augmenter
la taxe carbone vous diminuez des impôts
directs parce qu'un impôt indirect bon
croyez moi sur parole il est moins 10
torcy fils est moins nocive pour
l'économie qu'un impôt direct type
cotisations employeurs impôt sur les
sociétés impôt sur le revenu donc si
vous augmentez de 20 milliards par
exemple taxe carbone ou vos taxes
environnementales des cas due
concurrence vous baissez 20 milliards
vos impôts y ait vous avez une mesure
merveilleuse parce qu'elle est neutre
pour le déficit public elle contribue à
l'environnement et elle relance la
croissance plus que votre système fiscal
il est davantage un direct que direct et
les impôts indirects sont moins dix
sportifs que les impôts directs c'est ce
qu'on appelle le double dividende
le premier point sur la taxe carbone sur
la taxe environnementale le deuxième
point c'est que là je crois que pour le
décideur public ces questions de taxe
carbone est ce qu'on les a juste à la
baisse quand il ya une crise c'est ce
qu'on appelle en fait en économie
l'incohérence temporel mais c'est à dire
les quand vous avez objectifs de court
terme les objectifs de moyen long terme
qui vole pas ensemble alors ça ça nous
concerne tous par exemple quand on veut
faire un régime et qu'on dit de l'ain
j'arrête ça c'est une incohérence
temporel parce que si on veut vraiment
faire un régime il faut s'y mettre
aujourd'hui parce que si tous les jours
vous repoussée à demain vous avez envie
de manger votre tablette de chocolat à
court terme c'est la dernière fois et
toujours voué dix ans et trois ans après
vous êtes en train de descendre vos
tablettes de chocolat alors ça comment
est-ce qu'on résout ça alors on fait ça
c'est l'histoire lui c'est ici à rennes
puisque ulysse et les sirènes étaient
confrontés au même choix enfin la
réponse l'exemple est rigolo et la
conclusion est plus raide donc je parce
que je pense à l'exemple à court terme
son bénéfice était d'aller voir les
sirènes mais il savait qu'à moyen terme
elle allait le tuer est donc la solution
pour éviter de faire la boulette de
court terme c'était il s'est donc il
s'est donc encore des homes a essayé ni
des boulettes de siens dans les oreilles
pour entendre et il ya donc en clair les
économistes ont beaucoup travaillé là
dessus la solution pour éviter ça c'est
la contrainte
c'est une règle de loi voire
constitutionnel qui empêche les
décideurs publics de céder
à dire aux sirènes
c'est un langage qui est un peu les
entendre c'est pour ça que les banques
centrales sont indépendantes aujourd'hui
c'est que ça a évité ou directeur du
trésor de dire aux gouverneurs de la
banque centrale manipuler les mois les
taux à neuf mois des présidentielles
donc voila ca c
c'est le côté voilà l'incohérence
temporelle pour éviter ça c'est
soit faut être très auto disciplinés
mais c'est pas facile
soit faut une contrainte dans des textes
pour éviter de faire ce à quoi le
premier constat que nous pouvons faire
et vous en avait déjà parlé
de cette période mais aussi des 20
dernières années
et que la libéralisation à l'extrême du
marché de l'énergie ne fonctionne pas
bien au contraire à les pénaliser nantes
pour notre pays et surtout pour groupe
edf et surtout pour les consommateurs
qui ne cesse de voir leur facture
augmenter donc face à ce constat ce
terrible constat j'ai quelques questions
à vous poser tout d'abord sur l'europe
de l'énergie qui est aujourd'hui
confrontée à ses propres limites on se
rend compte de la déconnexion existante
entre la formation des prix de
l'électricité au niveau européen et la
structure des coûts réels pour les parcs
de production des états membres et cette
déconnexion pénalise où vous l'avez dit
vous-même fortement notre pays ainsi à
l'aube de la présidence française de
l'union européenne que pourrait
concrètement faire éconduire le
gouvernement pour changer la donne
ensuite la transition énergétique et la
maintenance de nos centrales nucléaires
pourrait conduire selon certaines
estimations ont peut-être partagez vous
cet avis
en tout cas c'est l'avis de l'économiste
patrick artus a doublé le prix d'énergie
en euros constants sur les 20 prochaines
années
cette hausse s'expliquerait par les
investissements nécessaires pour
compenser l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables vous avez un peu abordée
mais papa pas suffisamment à mon goût
mais aussi pour entretenir notre parc
nucléaire qui est vieillissant et
nécessite des investissements importants
donc ma question est assez simple quel
est votre regard sur cette analyse est
est-ce qu'une telle hausse est
envisageable et se fera t-elle sur le
dos des consommateurs une autre question
rapide son chèque énergie vous en avez
parlé aussi mais
ça peut être une réponse alors vous
l'avez dit
conjoncturel mais en tout cas le suite à
une étude de l'ademe le montant de ce
chèque énergie devrait s'élever à 710
euros alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est 277
euros pour les familles en plus grande
difficulté plus 100 euros
supplémentaires pour cette année il ya
quand même un delta important quel est
votre avis à ce sujet là est ce que
c'est un bon outil et puis j'ai une
dernière question suite à votre
présentation vous ai parlé que nos
voisins européens avait fait le choix ou
moi je passais un choix en tout cas de
ne pas stocker du gaz
pour l'avenir en particulier l'allemagne
et votre inquiétude et vous l'avez dit
c'est qu'on était capables ou en france
2 de subvenir à nos besoins mais si nos
voisins nous en demande et on serait en
difficulté ma question est peut-être
naïve mais pourquoi finalement nos
voisins de stock pas voilà merci merci
jean claude donc on passe alors en du
plan et ensuite alain cadec merci madame
la présidente monsieur le professeur à
vous écouter
on apprend beaucoup de choses moi qui
suis pas un spécialiste de l'énergie et
pourtant malgré tout je fais un
parallèle quasiment identique avec la
problématique qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
sur l'agriculture et sur l'alimentation
je me dis que dans ce pays nous sommes
totalement incapable d'avoir une vraie
stratégie et la réalité de tout ce que
vous venez de dire confirme que nous
n'avons pas de stratégie parce que si
nous avions une stratégie on aurait
essayé trouver les solutions pour
pallier à ces déficits alors que nous
étions un pays qui a produit de
l'énergie décarbonée avec le nucléaire
le plus vite le plus rapide et de façon
la plus importante
est qu'aujourd'hui quand je dis que nous
n'avons aucune stratégie etc c'est le
sens de ma question est ce que vous
pensez que véritablement on est une
stratégie énergétique en termes de
production en france on a sans arrêt des
injonctions contradictoires
le bois a été supprimée alors que la
moitié ou presque la moitié 40% de la
surface de la france est occupée par la
forêt a carrément été supprimée de toute
possibilité ou presque de chauffage
à part un peu de granulés mais qu
utilise aussi de l'énergie pour faire
reconnu et alors qu il plus facile de
mettre une bûche directement dans la
cheminée c'est pareil sur le gaz on a
voulu lancer la méthanisation
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que sur
les différentes mesures normes icpe ça
deviendrait plus en plus difficile et
que nous sommes en train quasiment de
tuer la filière nous u exactement le
même sujet sur le photovoltaïque on a
incité le photovoltaïque avec un tarif
de rachat 0,65 cent soixante cinq
centimes d'euro au kilo à tort pour
descendre aujourd'hui à 9,8 centimes et
donc tuer toute la filière de production
de panneaux photovoltaïques qui avaient
été mises en place dans les années 2010
2011 2012 on n'a aucune stratégie sur
l'hydroélectricité alors qu'on a un pays
qui est parcouru par des fleuves qui
pourrait largement produire de l'énergie
là aussi totalement décarbonée on a
aucune possibilité même sur les toutes
petites turbines sur les seuils je
rappelle qu'en france sous louis xiv il
y avait quarante mille seuil qui
fonctionnait nous en avons aujourd'hui
14000 qui pourraient continuer de
fonctionner et dogmatiquement par
principe environnementale on s'interdit
de réfléchir à foie gras faire
fonctionner ces son rang donc monsieur
le professeur est ce que vous pensez pas
que la france marche sur la tête et qu'à
force de marcher sur la tête et de
penser uniquement comme vous l'avez dit
que la seule solution est d'aller
chercher dans la dette publique dans la
dette publique la réponse aux maux de
nos errances de ne jamais avoir eu de
stratégie depuis 20 à 30 ans est ce que
vous pensez pas que ça aura des limites
et est ce que vous pensez pas qu un jour
ou l'autre le vrai développement durable
serait plutôt se poser ces questions-là
très bien alors on passe à alain cadec
ensuite pierre l'eau
écoutez je vais essayer de faire marcher
sur la tête d'abord merci monsieur
venant pour vos éclairages sur la hausse
des prix de l'énergie
vous l'avez dit depuis le 1er octobre
2021 le prix du gaz a augmenté de plus
de 12% par rapport au barème en vigueur
il s'agit là de là
plus forte hausse constatée depuis 2013
alors vous avez évoqué le long terme au
24 avril 2022 c'est un peu vrai c'est
donc dans un contexte de haute de 2 de
hausse des tarifs réglementés du gaz de
l'électricité et du carburant certains
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
formules diverses propositions pour
alléger la facture des ménages
l'un fait la promesse de lutter contre
la précarité énergétique et de garantir
à chacun l'accès aux biens de première
nécessité en proposant une tarification
progressive de l'énergie et l'eau qui
seraient rendues gratuites sur les
premiers mètres cubes pour les ménages
idem pour les premiers mégawattheures
d'électricité
un autre souhaite mettre à contribution
les dividendes des actionnaires vous
avez deviné qui c'était un troisième
souhaite diminuer la fiscalité sur les
carburants sans plus de précision une
quatrième
s'engage pour une diminution durable de
la fiscalité elle entend pour cela
supprimer le système des taxes sur les
taxes pour rappel une tva de 20 %
s'applique sur les taxes de consommation
de gaz et d'électricité vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure d'ailleurs qui
vient alourdir un peu plus la facture au
moment de l'achat du produit pétrolier
enfin un dernier candidat réaffirme son
soutien pour la filière nucléaire qu'il
considère comme seul moyen de ne pas
voir une explosion de la facture
d'énergie dans les années qui viennent
alors
manifestement je sais pas si on marche
sur la tête mais ya pas de recette
miracle
cependant pour vous quelle pourrait être
la meilleure mesures à adopter pour
stabiliser le prix de l'énergie en
respectant évidemment les règles du
marché
merci à là on passe à pia l'eau est
ensuite eveline renault garabédian
oui brillamment
pensez vous qu'aujourd'hui on n'aurait
pas la capacité
de mieux contrôler le prix de vente de
notre énergie le nucléaire un prix de
revient beaucoup plus bas donc on est
non pas furent un cours mondial mais sur
un prix de production
et le prix du gaz est atténué par nos
capacités de stockage vous avez dit 25%
c'est à dire que là où je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous quand on stocke on
achète au prix bas et on revend au prix
moyen aujourd'hui en stock on a acheté
au prix bas et on veut revendre au prix
fort est-ce que là il n'y a pas une
solidarité nationale que notre économie
pourrait supporter alors eveline et
ensuite patrick chaize merci madame la
présidente monsieur ghosn ans nous avons
parlé beaucoup ce matin de la hausse du
prix de l'électricité
je souhaiterais mois avoir votre avis
sur les perspectives à long terme liées
à la transition écologique et notamment
la question sur le coup des métaux le
déploiement massif des énergies
renouvelables et nouvelles formes de
mobilité nécessite l'utilisation très
importante et en grande quantité des
métaux la composition technologique
permettant le passage à une énergie
propre ce dont a parlé tout à l'heure
l'hydrogène le solaire l'éolien les
systèmes électriques implique l'emploi
massif de métaux que ce soit des métaux
dits critiques ou bien des terres rares
on a vu au cours de ces douze derniers
mois une augmentation très importante
des terres rares pouvez vous nous
indiquer selon vous comment évolueront
le coup de métaux d'ici les prochains
mois ou les prochaines années et quelles
seront les conséquences sur les
industries technologiques et plus
généralement sur nos objectifs du
développement durable merci patrick
chaize et ensuite faire q persie merci
présidente professeur
cette semaine le président de la cré
genre soit 40 qu a annoncé que le prix
de l'électricité n'avait pas évolué
faiblement évolué et que ce sera être
durable est-ce que donc par rapport à
vos propos vous pouvez adhérer à ce
concept
concernant donc le gaz il a affirmé que
les prix du gaz serait gelé et que au
moins jusqu'en juillet 2022 alors ses
passifs liés à des événements mais en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il a affirmé ou
alors si c'est par rapport à une
évolution du prix du gaz qu'on peut
imaginer qu'ils permettraient
d'équilibrer jusqu'à cette date les
échos
je suis surpris par vos propos
et par vous les éléments que vous donnez
sur un point c'est le fait qu'on n'ait
pas pu anticiper et prévoir cette
évolution certes c'est conjoncturel mais
il me semble que
on a donc on avait un certain nombre
d'éléments qui ne pouvait nous permettre
de d'apprécier donc cette évolution
pourquoi à votre avis on a été donc
aussi peu
précautionneux dans ses prévisions
alors pierre kuipers et ensuite
françoise férat oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le professeur
j'ai l'impression qu'on vient paradoxe
extraordinaire
puisque certains veulent notamment
l'état supprimé moteur thermique dans
les années qui viennent et en mettant le
tout électrique est ce que vous êtes une
analyse précise c'est un bilan sur ce
que peut représenter le développement de
l'électricité concerne sachant que tout
ce que vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
nous montre toute la fragilité de nos
approvisionnements et puisqu'on ne peut
pas en plus le stocker je crois qu'on
est en train de faire une erreur
historique en voulant supprimer le
moteur thermique en tout cas le pétrole
par rapport et le substitut et avec de
l'électricité sur le gaz
est-ce que vous avez mesuré aussi
l'impact que nous vivons actuellement du
coût du gaz qui est de 2 x 6 par rapport
à l'année dernière et qui vont entraîner
pour l'agriculture notamment
des ruptures d'approvisionnement
au delà des coûts prohibitifs pour la
zot donc les engrais minéraux
voilà et puis concernant le prix du
méthane est ce que vous mesurez bien le
prix de l'indépendance énergétique de
notre pays puisque on voit bien qu'on
est dépendant du reste du monde et la
minéralité n'a jamais été aussi grand
françoise férat et ensuite fabien gay
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur pour la clarté de votre
intervention j'ai lu récemment un
article consacré ça ne surprendra pas à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie en
europe et cet article aborde un certain
nombre de points que nous avons évoqué
ce matin je n'y reviens pas je vais en
sortir si vous me le permettez
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il existait une
proposition espagnole de création d'une
centrale européenne d'achat du gaz ça me
semble intéressant à l'énoncé pouvez
vous m'en dire un peu plus et surtout
nous donner et partager votre avis sur
ce point merci françoise fabian invité
jean-pierre moga bonjour monsieur le
professeur je voulais vous remercier de
votre propos mais on a un désaccord
c'est moi on a un désaccord profond
d'ailleurs vous avez vous avez dit au
bout de 45 minutes de discours
politiques ou faisait pas de politique
ça m'a fait un peu rire
non moi aussi je vais pas faire de
politique j'ai arrêté ce matin
mais le désaccord profond ce que nous
avons entre nous c'est que vous vous
placez dans le marché mais ce que je
respecte totalement et dans l'europe de
l'énergie et depuis depuis barcelone
2002 et moi je pense que c'est en partie
une un de nos problèmes et vous vous
pensez qu'en partie ça sera une solution
non mais on a fait l'europe de l'énergie
pourquoi en disant aux consommateurs et
aux consommatrices ça va baisser la
facture électrique sauf que depuis 20
ans c'est plus 70% et le mécanisme vous
avez décrit il est il est fondamental
mais il faut l'expliquer
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le coût de
production c'est le dernier
kilowattheure produit
et il se trouve que souvent le dernier
c'est par le gaz etc quand il augmente
et il a triplé en deux ans avoue tripler
la facture électrique puisque vous avez
corrélés le 1 lorsque vous avez très
bien expliquée plus le co2 que ça
augmente et donc moi je voulais vous
poser une question précise
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que c'est
une crise aujourd'hui structurel pas
conjoncturelle structurelle du mode de
la construction du prix qui aujourd'hui
en jeu et la deuxième et deuxième chose
évidemment je suis pour ressortir
l'énergie du marché libérale donc ça
c'est un désaccord
au fond deuxième question et je vais
très vite mais vous y avez répondu vous
n'êtes pas favorable à une baisse de la
fiscalité notamment la tva pourtant si
on passait la tva de 19,6 à 5,5 c'est à
dire en reconnaissant l'énergie comme
produits de première nécessité
c'est entre 350 et 500 aux parents pour
les ménages je plaide pour ça et je suis
d'accord avec vous sur la question du
chèque énergie et juge je me permets une
réflexion mais elle et elle est
franchement nous j'ai pas beaucoup
apprécié la dernière phrase de votre
propos sur le pull sur le pull je vais
m'en expliquer en 10 secondes celle des
mâles j'ai déjà eu à et monsieur lévy se
racheta y mettons pull ici et je crois
et je me mets dedans personnes à deux
difficultés à payer sa facture
d'électricité et de gaz personne et je
me mets dedans mais il ya 10 millions de
nos concitoyens qui sont en précarité
énergétique et y en a qui seront obligés
de mettre un pull voir des fois deux
pulls à leurs enfants parce qu'ils
peuvent pas payer la facture électrique
et ça cette blague elle me met un peu
mal simplement les ans je vous le dis
mais c'est exactement le même la même
chose avec monsieur lévy soit là je te
mets ton pull vous êtes un professeur
reconnu vous êtes ceux parmi ceux qui
forme les élites de demain et je veux
pas laisser passer des propos comme ça
tous remercient je partage la part des
choses entre le structurel et le
conjoncturel souvent l'un influence
l'autre et vous avez très bien souligné
notre dépendance en matière de gaz entre
l'europe du nord la russie et et le
maghreb ça c'est structurel cette
dépense cette dépendance là vous avez
évoqué du coup dans un second propos
le biogaz on nous a dit et ses récents
en france
de pouvoir réinjectée dans le réseau du
biogaz c'est très très récent donc c'est
pas mature les choses sont pas
complètement maîtrisé tech techniquement
mais le saurons vous l'avez évoqué aussi
on nous a très vite dit les
inconvénients notamment que c'était pas
compétitifs c'était pas compétitif que
le prix était bas
quand le prix du biarrot on peut
s'interroger sur la compétitivité de la
production de biogaz moi je crois que
nous n'avons des réponses que à la
conjoncture vous avez évoqué les choix
politiques nous n'avons jamais de
réponse sur le structurel moi je suis un
fervent défenseur des équilibres et de
l'aménagement du territoire et je vois
dans la production de biogaz
vraiment un moyen si on veut le regarder
attentivement à levier d'aménagement du
territoire de pérennisation des
exploitations agricoles et de circuits
courts de l'énergie et je n'entends pas
cela dans les choix politiques gens
qu'on souligne toujours les contraintes
il y en aura toujours suffit de les
régler enfin tout problème a sa solution
donc pardon parce que vous l'avez évoqué
dans un second temps j'aimerais parole
mais je pense que c'est une façon de
voir les choses au delà de l'énergie
d'un prix c'est aussi comment on fait
vivre notre pays en la matière merci aux
sénateurs tissot la libéralisation du
secteur de l'énergie qu'est ce que ça a
apporté aux consommateurs il ya une
chose qui est certaine ya une chose qui
est plus compliqué c'est une rotation 1
alors en fait là le problème est un peu
méthologique c'est à dire
c'est qu'elle est le point de
comparaison parce qu'on dit ça n'a pas
bénéficié au consommateur parce que les
prix ont augmenté de temps oui mais en
99 le baril était à 9 dollars
en 2011 il était à 110 dollars 110 alain
donc c'est normal que les prix de l'élec
depuis 20 ans en moyenne et augmenter
donc la question c'est de savoir s'il
n'y avait pas une libéralisation
il aurait augmenté de combien de plus
et à cette question là il n'y a pas de
réponse claire alors moi je j'ai une
autre réponse sur la libéralisation qui
sait qu'elle est légale la libération du
marché l'énergie eh ben on le voit
jamais dans la presse mais ils sont
importants c'est la transparence des
prix et des coûts
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on sait exactement
combien ça coûte de transporter 1
mégawatt heure d'élèves sur un talent
aujourd'hui on sait très bien comment ça
coûte de
commercialiser de l'élec chez madame
michu à carpentras aujourd'hui on sait
très bien où sont les coûts sont les
prix avant je dis pas que c'était
nécessairement le cauchemardesque avant
mais avant le marché du gaz s'était
aussi ghazi autour d'une table qui se
partageaient le gaz russe norvégien et
anglais il y avait aucune transparence
vous saviez pas où étaient les prix elle
n'est pas où étaient les coûts et donc
il y avait des marges
avec la transparence des prix et des
coûts sur le marché européen je dis pas
que tout est parfait mais on sait
exactement qu'est ce qui coûte quoi et
combien et donc a priori ça fait moins
de marge
et ça c'est quand même un élément de
transparence qui à mon avis est
important estimé décisif le débat peut
être ouvert
mais c'est quand même important c'est
quand même important
artus qui dit les prix de l'énergie fois
2e en 20 ans
l'avantagé c'est que peut-être que moi
je serai pas à la retraite dans 20 ans
mais personne pourra vérifier si elle
fait ou pas la vérité c'est que les prix
l'énergie ça peut évoluer très vite et
c'est très difficile de prévoir à long
terme les prix de l'électricité quand je
les dis qu'il ya beaucoup de raisons
pour qu'ils augmentent mais pour
introduire un élément peut-être de
soulagement relatif
les prix l'énergie par exemple prix du
pétrole
pour avoir travaillé un peu avec eux ce
qu'ils savent de quoi ils parlent en la
matière les saoudiens les prix du
pétrole ils y voient à long terme très à
la baisse
très à la baisse parce que ils savent
très bien que la transition énergétique
ce dans le monde c'est moins de
consommation de pétrole et donc quand
ils font des simulations enfin je ne
sais pas donc je peux dire ce qu'ils
m'ont fait faire quand il faut commandes
quand ils font des simulations à long
terme du prix du baril du prennent 12
dollars
pourquoi parce que 12 dollars c'est le
coût complet de production du baril de
pétrole dans leurs champs pétrolifères
le moins compétitif
donc oui le prix l'électricité va
augmenter oui le prix du gaz aussi sans
doute le prix du pétrole c'est pas chez
eux et comme c'est un indicateur très
important pour tous les marchés de
l'économie
je serai moins un certificat patrick
artus
mais c'est vrai que la tendance dans les
5 à 10 années on la voit quand même pas
à la baisse sur l'électricité sur le
chèque énergie l'ademe demande cette
séance 710 euros la dépense moyenne
d'électricité d'un ménage qui se chauffe
à lélex est de l'ordre de 1500 euros si
vous lui donnez 710 euros en gros vous
payer la moitié de sa facture
ça veut dire qu'il ya toute une frange
de la population qui contribue plus à la
transition énergétique à la limitation
de la pollution
subventionné oui prendre la moitié en
charge suis pas su en jeu ça me semble
beaucoup mais
je pense qu'on bascule dans dans une
situation on immuniserait complètement
les ménages des consommations d'énergie
et c'est juste pas cohérent avec
l'objectif la transition énergétique
pourquoi est ce que nous faisons ce
tokpa joker je n'ai pas le temps de
regarder
je sais pas exactement
sénateur je suis trop long
sénateur du plomb on n'a pas de
stratégie bah oui on est parti je suis
d'accord avec vous
mais bien de vous
on n'a pas de stratégie de fait qu'on a
été de fait qu'on a été surpris de fait
on a été surpris ça me permet de
répondre aussi à d'autres d'autres
questions qui ont été posées à la limite
si l'exercice européen en cours qu'à
lancer un certain nombre de ministres
espagnol français
pour vous savez cette espèce de boîte à
outils là toolkit comme on dit à
bruxelles si cet exercice peut être
utile ce serait précisément peut-être de
fixer un peu des règles de coordination
jeu centraliserait pas les choses ou
européen mais de coordination des pays
en matière en cas de crise parce qu'il
est clair que c'est du vu cette crise là
on n'a pas très bien vu venir si on peut
effectivement faire une politique de
mécanismes de coordination entre les
producteurs et des transporteurs et
distributeurs
ça serait bien parce qu'en fait on c'est
vrai que le secteur et pensait jamais
qu'on pourrait avoir un prix du lait qui
resterait plusieurs jours au dessus de
200 euros le mégawattheure
donc là effectivement il ya sans doute
au niveau européen de la coordination à
réfléchir on a été surpris c'est un bon
effet vous avez parlé des drones
du micro hydroélectricité vous n'avez
pas évoquer là je les vois qu'ici la
technologie de l'ester méthylique de
colza
puisque pour les ménages qui sont en
milieu rural qui sont précaires
énergétiquement et qui sont pas reliés
au gaz et qui ont une cuve au fioul en
gros ça fait 2 à 3 millions de pauvres
est bien le fait de transformer le qubo
siu lan cuve en ester méthylique de
colza ça leur évite d'avoir ils
pourraient pas se payer une pompe à
chaleur tellement c'est cher ça évitera
que ça coûte cher aux finances publiques
il faut juste changer le brûleur ça
coûte 400 euros et vous pouvez mettre de
l'ester méthylique de colza se fait
fonctionner l'agriculture c'est un
business model qui est en train
d'émerger et qui à mon avis pour avoir
regardé le sujet de prêt peut être
soutenable à terme économique ans
sénateur khaled aouij les propositions
de mesures des candidats échouent
présidentielle
qu'est ce que
bon mois ce alors j'ai parlé l'isolation
thermique par dont
j'ai parlé l'isolation thermique je n'ai
pas eu la sobriété thermique le
mécanisme de thé icpe flottante c'est un
pisani que je trouve plutôt
pertinent dans le contexte actuel
sous l'hypothèse qu'elles soient bien
flottante
on fait toujours des trucs qui flottent
quand ça monte et puis il remonte pas
quand ça baisse donc il faut s'assurer
de l'asymétrie du dispositif dans le
temps quand j'étais jeune je commençais
à bercy j'ai un vague souvenir de la tpp
flottante à l'époque et je peux vous
dire qu'elle n'a pas floutés
donc ça c'est un poids important
sénateurs luo
avec le nucléaire on pourrait vendre
moins cher sa boucle avec d'ailleurs une
autre question sur
win
parce qu'en fait le raisonnement tient
derrière c'est dit on veut pas payer
l'électricité au prix du dernier
mégawattheure produit qui est produit
par une centrale au gaz
j'entends mais ma réponse c'est dire oui
mais le dernier mégawattheure produit
par celui qui produit l'électricité à
partir du gaz c'est celui qui me protège
du black out
parce que sauf vous savez une centrale
nucléaire c'est un peu ce sens un peu un
gros paquebot et donc la demande
d'électricité elles varient au cours
d'une journée facilement de 50 60 70 %
les centrales nucléaires pour des
raisons physiques on les modules assez
peu c'est à dire que le volume de
production d'une centrale nucléaire
est assez
enfin on peut pas le changer de 30% au
cours d'une journée alors aidé autant
ils ont du mal à construire des idées
centrales je tire pas sur le pianiste
mais ils savent quand même bien les
exploiter on est d'un pays au monde qui
sait le mieux faire les modulations de
centrales nucléaires mais yann limites
physiques c'est que quand vous me lisez
beaucoup une centrale nucléaire vous
avez des gaz rares qui apparaissent dans
le coeur et donc faut les retirer alors
je suis pas chimistes du avoir dû et non
de l'argon et quand vous avez une
demande qui est très volatile vous
pouvez pas être en permanence en train
de la fournir avec une centrale
nucléaire c'est ça que je veux dire et
si vous essayez de le faire vous avez un
risque de black out et finalement le
fait de payer cher les gars
l'électricité en ce moment la stratégie
ça se traduit par une chose c'est que on
a de la lumière dans 7 5
et à titre personnel moi je suis prêt à
payer pour cent
mais voilà sa cessation tout seul à la
réponse
il est alors sénateur madame la
sénatrice renault a mis non s'agit je
reviendrai peut-être un presse que ces
longs sénateurs chaise
j'avais pas que j'en ferai ce que jean
que monsieur
car un coup la question et il a repris
je savais pas qu'il avait dit que le
prix de l'électricité augmentent répand
alors il ya des
gars assez c'est une conjecture je
comprends
alors ça dépend ce qui veut dire par là
il faudra poser la question si de toute
façon il ya des tags c'est à dire que la
creuse est missionné de par la loi pour
évoluer les coûts de production de
l'électricité et l'envoie ça au ministre
en disant donc les tarifs réglementés
l'électricité devraient évoluer de temps
pour couvrir les coûts parce que la loi
prévoit que les tarifs réglementés
d'électricité couplées coût d'un
opérateur efficace après c'est le
gouvernement qui décide si ça monte ou
pas
si les coûts ont augmenté ce qui est
quand même assez probable probable parce
que
abl à ce moment là la creule constatera
elle fera son métier je n'anticipe pas
sur ce qu'elle fera je suis pas et je
suis plus commissaire de la creuse en
relation avec eux mais le mécanisme est
là creux constatera 6 à augmenter ou pas
s'il faut faire un mouvement tarifaire
ont pas et le ministre décidera s'il
fait un mouvement tarifaire ou pas et
s'il ya quelqu'un sur le marché un
opérateur qui trouve que la décision lui
convient pas il fera ce qui s'est fait
beaucoup de fois depuis dix ans il fait
un recours au conseil d'état
qui sera probablement pas traitée en
référé et qui sera traité au fond après
mes 2022
je crois que j'ai répondu à votre
question
sur le prix du gaz on n'a pas anticipé
non est ce qu'on aurait pu anticiper
oui en arguant sur le fait qu' une
sortie de crise pandémique c'est très
rapide en termes de reprise le niveau de
production d'or économique
on a un peu alors après je peux vous
dire que c'est difficile de faire des
prévisions qui sont pessimistes parce
qu'après quand vous sortez je dirais du
milieu du débat les gens voudront vous
être trop pessimiste ou autre et donc
vous n'êtes pas entendu donc parfois
avoir raison trop tôt c'est un exercice
qui n'est pas facile aussi mais en tout
cas enfin là je dors sur mes deux
oreilles ce que moi j'avais fait une
étude on met demeurer en dix ans le jour
où la dernière vague pandémique est
passé ça va repartir très vite et ça on
avait de la littérature académique là
dessus et de fait c'est reparti très
vite y compris en chine à sénateurs
kuypers
bercy bon alors je répondrais peut-être
si j'ai le temps
sénatrice fera la proposition espagnole
de création d'une centrale européenne
d'achat de gaz
donc j'avais donné quelques éléments
tout à l'heure pour dire que
j'étais pas très favorable le cinquième
élément que je pourrais ajouter c'est
que je préférais que les opérateurs
gaziers qui sont pas si nombreux que ça
se coordonnent plutôt que de créer un
nouvel établissement public européen
avec les interférences qui peuvent
exister dans ce type de situation
je préférerais que ce soit plutôt
décentralisées comme disent les
économistes plutôt que centraliser donc
ne se soit plutôt un mécanisme de
coordination ce qui est rapide et facile
à mettre en place plutôt que créer
excusez moi un nouveau machin je sais
dans les instances parlementaires on
n'aime pas quand on crée de nouveau
machin donc on aussi je n'aime pas trop
ça que créer un nouvel établissement
public ça mettrait du temps et puis et
puis bon en face vous avez gazprom et
poutine donc ça devient très politique
si on centralise à mon âge il à la
discussion mais bon le sujet en cours
d'examen c'est un sentiment
préliminaires alors sénateur gay je
prends votre point sur le pull
je ferai attention je tâcherai de
trouver autre chose alors si j'étais un
peu taquin si vous me permettrez les
scissions leur faisait d'isolation
thermique qui mettrait un petit un pue
un peu plus petit que celui qui met en
ce moment parce qu'ils vivent dans le
froid je ferai attention à ça je suis
preneur du poids je tâcherai jeu je
tiens à dire que quand j'ai découvert
sur twitter que monsieur lévy parler de
mme et ont pu qui avait un hashtag
j'étais content et un peu saumâtre parce
que moi ça fait des années que jean
faire laver étudiants donc j'avais
l'impression qu'on m'avait prédit des
mais c'est une idée
je ne réfléchirai aux termes employés
sur l'europe de l'énergie j'ai répondu
au sénateur tissot tout à l'heure en
disant que ça va contribuer à la
transparence des coûts est ce que la
crise est structurelle
non je pense que la crise ce serait face
the seeds et ça vous avez peut-être
trouvé que je me répète la crise ne
viendrais structurels si on a un black
out
le black out c'est le péché grave du
système électrique c'est à dire si votre
système électrique fait un black out il
faut vous le changez c'est arrivé en
californie au début des années 2000 m
parce qu'ils ont ils
pas ce qu'ils ont
si j'étais contre taquin je dirais
qu'ils non libéralisée que la moitié de
la chaîne de valeur et c'est à dire
qu'ils ont libéralisé des choses
je suis allé sur la libéralisation je ne
suis pas un fou furieux je reviendrai
sur la libéralisation
mais la crise n'est pas structurelle
parce que parce qu'on a les lampes qui
marche dans cette salle le jour où on
serait dans le loir là on sera là il
faudra changer profondément de trucs
mais pour l'instant depuis 76 ça
fonctionne donc fin de mon point de vue
faire baisser la tva 19,6 à 5,5
je n'ignore pas les difficultés de mes
concitoyens mais
je pense c'est compliqué si la
transition énergétique n'est que sur une
partie de la population
et pas nécessairement sur sur les autres
c'est la tva je suis pour tout le monde
va falloir
pourquoi pas mais là c'est contraire
avec l'objectif d'une transition
énergétique qui consiste à faire en
sorte que les gens payent davantage
quand ils ont des comportements qui
génère de la pollution
c'est ça la ccsn questions d'objectif
d'objectifs politiques cclat vous
subventionnez la consommation d'énergie
alors sénateur moga
redistribution des recettes tirées du
carbone est ce qu'on pourrait enfiler au
coin de passer aux bas revenus alors la
réponse est oui la réponse est oui parce
que tout à l'heure quand j'ai dit second
dividende c'est j'augmente ma taxe
carbone et puis je leur cycle sous forme
de baisses d'impôts directs et peut-être
que vous ai dit oh là là quand même yes
ces entreprises cotisations patronales
c'est les entreprises il en faut un peu
pour les ménages donc une façon
acceptable et économiquement acceptable
aussi de faire c'est de recycler une
partie petit à majoritaire des recettes
liées de la taxe carbone sur les ménages
sur la sobriété énergétique
oui alors c'est d'autant plus vrai que
les missiles que trois grands leviers la
transition énergétique pour le
développement des énergies renouvelables
même si vous en faites plein vous
n'arriverez pas à la neutralité carbone
la taxe carbone même si vous la mettez à
300 euros la tonne etes-vous tué
l'industrie française même en cumulant
ces deux choses là vous êtes toujours
pas à la neutralité carbone il faut
rajouter de l'efficacité énergétique est
sain pour un certain nombre de motifs
que je vais pas expliquer c'est pas très
facile parce que les effets des gains
d'efficacité énergétique sur la
pollution sont amortis par ce qu'on
appelle un effet rebond est donc en fait
si on veut vraiment arriver à la
sobriété énergétique la dernière cassée
la sobriété énergétique il ya aussi pas
en tous les appareils électroniques en
veine il faut savoir que 10 % de la
consommation d'électricité et les lier à
des appareils électroniques qui reste en
veille le fait de fermer ses volets ou
ses rideaux le soir la nuit ça évite le
rayonnement thermique de votre habitat
il ya plein de petits réflexes comme ça
effectivement de des campagnes publiques
sur la sobriété sans me semblerait
bienvenue sénateurs schuwey sur le gaz
qui dépend des russes structurel il est
ou non non excusez moi
il ya quand même beaucoup d'éléments
enfin je maintiens quand même que dans
cette crise a beaucoup d'éléments qui
sont conjoncturelles et les anglais vont
commencer à reproduire les russes encore
une fois comme je les dis ils sont
entrés dans le détail sont pas
complètement market maker ils sont
vraiment liées par des contrats long
terme alors c'est vrai que la
compétitivité relative du biogaz est en
train d'augmenter par rapport à celle du
gaz naturel vous avez raison de le
souligner et sur l'équilibré territoire
sur le biogaz alors je suis tellement
d'accord avec vous que j'ai même écrit
un rapport pour la crèche sur le sujet
c'est à dire que 1 des uns des aspects
intéressants de la problématique du
biogaz
c'est que ça fait un circuit et les
énergies qui court entre les campagnes
les territoires et les milieux urbains
là le territoire fabricant le gaz qui
est consommé par la ville et ça permet
de faire un aménagement du territoire
intelligent et harmonieux
arguments qui à mon avis angie devrait
sortir plus souvent dans tout cas
absolument donc si vous taper mon nom et
éclairer l'avenir vous tombez sur un
rapport sur nouveaux territoires
nouvelle logique que j'ai remis à la
craie ya deux ans donc je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous
[Musique]